tell us what you've learned from him in
the concept of feminism
oh i think feminism lies to women so i
think they tell you to chase the bag um
chase the bag follow your career and
someone is still going to want you at
the end of it and i think that is a lie
i think men don't prefer older women and
i think they don't prefer career women
and a lot of times these women end up
single childless and alone because
feminism
told them that that was going to get
them the results that it wanted that
they wanted and it doesn't
yes i have pretty strong feelings yeah
all right ally you want to react to that
i don't like feminism at all i've never
even identified as a feminist you have
to think i'm a latina that grew up in a
lower socioeconomic status and a single
mother home to me feminism just seemed
like an affluent white woman problem i
was like what are the complaints
what what really don't we have in the
west i served in the united states army
they let me do that so i just don't see
it and you can look around and women are
oppressed they keep saying that we're
oppressed but then we're also empowered
and so how do i know when to assume
responsibility for the outcomes of my
life i think that that's a poor message
to sell to young girls especially with
the rise of fatherless homes that's a
that's a horrible message so subscribe
to our channels yeah and i also wanted
to say i think being a woman is an
advantage not a disadvantage in business
um i i i think that the girls that say
that like their genders holding them
back in business tend to be lazy and
that's actually why they're held back
really yeah why do you feel that way
why because
it's not that hard to be successful
until you like that kim kardashian video
get your [ __ ] ass up from work a
little bit yeah
so you girls listen to kim kardashian
when it comes to that oh
no no you love kevin i love her okay
i'll tell you a few stories after the
show yeah
i mean
the quote sure i just i i think people
that are always blaming the world for
their problems are usually lazy and it's
usually them because they're the common
denominator in all those situations
like you've got a lot of wisdom in
you're in here you know you were raised
he's right well it comes from my dad
shout out shout out to papa pearl
uh you brought up that uh i think ali
said
uh feminism is an affluent white woman
problem
coco
as an affluent white woman i wouldn't
know she's ukrainian that's like
different i'm never the other white
croatian yeah but your thoughts on
feminism they've they've been
anti-feminism uh i don't really have
much to say about feminism because i
feel like the term has been just like
thrown around like everybody has a
different definition and
i just don't want to get into it gotcha
but has it been a net positive or net
negative for women what do you mean fem
feminism has it been a positive or a
negative for women depends on the
situation but overall when you think
when you think of the word feminism are
you like yay feminism or boo feminist
well i'll tell you something about
feminism i posted a video that women
should like shave and i was attacked by
a lot of women telling me that they
they can grow their hair if they want to
and i'm like you do whatever you want to
do like i'm just telling you guys don't
really like hair okay and they were like
you're an anti-feminist i'm like no i
just
like something
yeah well
the reason i've asked this because i
remember when ali and i spoke at the cme
shout out to the conference for
masculine excellence uh i said ali
you're stud i go but that's for what if
i if a guy did an interview or had some
of these thoughts of a dude you're stud
i said what's the female
version of a stud and you said it was
being a
feminine woman
right being feminine so
what's the differentiator between being
feminine and feminism can you explain
for some reason
i believe feminism basically says that
femininity is a weakness and so we as
women we should suppress that because
that's going to get us in
poor outcomes these large boogeyman
situations they come up with you know
men leaving you you getting punched in
the face by a man or you know dragged
behind a dumpster all this like really
really weird and off things so
that i think sets women behind in the
dating market and then so it to me i
think it's a bunch of lonely women
trying to make other lonely women so
that they have somebody to hang out with
the crab mentality yes because if your
girlfriends go on they find love or even
if they find a career they will not be
at the bar with you friday to saturday
night it's just not gonna happen
so i that's what i think it's about and
i think it's about keeping jobs because
if we were to come out and say well you
know what
women are not really oppressed in the
west a lot of these non-profits would go
out of business there's i think there's
jobs on the line i think there's a
bottom
what is it bottom line in business as
well because i think that's why my tech
talk probably went viral is that it's
actually threatening i had somebody on a
reddit thread come out and say like this
is really good propaganda and it's like
it's not propaganda if leaving the
workforce and trusting a masculine man
to financially provide
i mean if that's propaganda then i want
it then i want it well and how are we
oppressed if there are quotas like there
are specific quotas for women that are
not offered to men scholarships grants
all of these things that are to aid and
help us there aren't there are not the
same there are not as many for men and
so how are we going to say oh we're so
oppressed but we have quotas grants all
of these non-profits that are there to
help us by the way
if we're if we were going to do a poll
uh of women at home
how many because you two have very
similar mindset is that fair to say red
pill women
is it fair to say that coco has got a
different perspective than you
fair
what percentage of women
would be more on
team ally team
pearl and what percentage of women would
be on team coco and what percentage of
women wouldn't be on either of your guys
teams like who would be like i hate them
all i think what do you think the answer
is i think the majority of women aren't
that opinionated
to be honest i think the majority of
people really because i know a lot of
opinionated women
honestly most girls i know just like
don't really care or follow this stuff
and they're like oh i don't want to talk
about politics talk about this stuff
about yeah but they got a lot of
opinions on a lot of
like the kind of other nonsense like the
kardashians maybe but okay but for those
that have opinions because i i think
that women do have opinions okay um
what percentage would you think be more
inclined to agree with you and what
would be more cocoa and it depends where
are you where are you
yeah this is a general question in the
uk women in the u.s women in the us
right so if you even have female viewers
because uh i don't know we're 90 male 90
so for the 10 of women out there um i
would say that like 90 of women would
agree with coco but would be absolutely
blind and think that they could even be
like her right this is not to gas you up
but you're a very attractive woman i'm
assuming you eat well i'm assuming you
go to the gym you're intelligent enough
to create a business a lot of women
would be like oh yeah i'm gonna follow
her it's like sis it's not you it's not
you
so yeah i think i think way to build her
up and then just take her down right
there not her no right
out there so that's what i think the
agreement would come out to is absolute
delusion they would think that you know
we're oppressed and then we have coco
here she's chasing a bag doing it well
wonderfully do you agree coco that most
women would more identify with your
mindset versus the ally and pro mindset
well the women i surround myself with
but i also think that not who you
surround yourself with women in general
if a million women were watching the
show what percentage are like yes coco
that's my girl and what percentage are
like no i'm on the alley pearl team i
think this is a hypothetical question
a lot of them would agree with me
but some of them would secretly agree
with them but then still vote for me
because they think that's politically
correct got it um
did you want something to add there
natalia
um no i think that's true i think a lot
of people would agree with uh coco
publicly
and then um you know internally have the
those feelings
let's take a second oh we're gonna say
something i just wanted to say like
living uh living this
i mean thinking like you guys thing like
there's nothing wrong with that it's
like you just have to find what works
for you if you're totally happy being at
home and being a mom and being a wife
and just like
living with your partner that's totally
fine like ever that's what i always say
when people ask me those questions like
oh coco when should i pay for dinner
coco when should i do this which like
when can i sleep with him like it's
totally up to you your life is up to you
so like whatever we say you can take it
in and then
decide for yourself let's